[Music]
hey guys we realized in our tour of the
office that we didn't show you guys the
magic and center fridge so you thought
we show you a little bit of the kind of
fuel it keeps the hustlers going every
day so I'll just take a look see what we
got here first of all a bunch of cheese
bunch bacon because we're living at keto
diet we also have fellow 100-150 eggs in
there you have a an empty jar of pickles
just the juice and there's a spoon in
there cool I got some more pickle thing
captain Delhi flight jalapenos some mild
pepper ratings stand up another empty
jar of pickles so that's that's like the
main food groups we got eggs bacon
pickles & Coke Zero favorite of our
founder sam and on the fridge you can
see we have all of our state Magnus new
varsity members from washington state
California Cleveland what was Indiana
was very the bird Jersey Texas so pretty
much from all over and that's pretty
much it guys thanks for checking it out
you